any place around the world even if
you're living far away from reefs they
matter to you and we have to come
together to protect and restore them
because really our lives depend on it
and it would be something quite tragic
to see such an incredible ecosystem
disappear on our watch
[Music]
coral vita is a mission driven social
enterprise that grows corals to restore
our world's dying reefs and my
co-founder and i launched coral vita
really from the back porch of our house
in grad school after about eight or nine
months we got our first investor on
board and slowly our second third and we
were able to raise our pre-seed round we
teamed up with leading coral scientists
around the world who pioneered these
methods to grow corals faster and make
them stronger they came on board as our
original advisors and ultimately we
settled on here grand bahama for our
first coral farm it's essential for
anyone doing this kind of work to
integrate local communities as much as
possible these aren't the reefs i grew
up alongside or depend upon so we're
very proud of the fact that more than
half of our staff are growing as
bahamian born bred raised uh bahamian as
a bohemian
the reef is like our second grocery
store
and throughout the years i've witnessed
our reef decline whereas true climate
change overfishing you can see
how detrimental these things are and an
ecosystem these are our underwater
rainforest basically
you may be wondering yourself what is a
coral and a lot of people think that
corals are colorful rocks in fact they
are animals that have plants living
inside of them that make rock for their
skeleton they're pretty epic three for
one and then these corals grow and grow
and they form reefs which in turn
provide the habitat for
so much life in the sea what we're
seeing right now though is that they are
dying half the world's coral reefs are
dead and over 90 are on track to die by
2050. there's a range of things that
threaten coral reef health habitat
destruction overfishing pollution but
more importantly than anything else and
we're seeing this right now is the
climate crisis warming and acidifying
oceans are killing corals in front of
our eyes the best thing to do for coral
reefs is to stop killing them which
requires our leaders to act on climate
destabilization and habitat destruction
but while we continue waiting for that
action we need new solutions to keep
reefs alive amidst the threats that they
face
coral farming is a process that's pretty
at the end of the day simple when it
comes to how this actually works a lot
our focus is on going out and collecting
pieces of coral from out on the reefs
but we also really try to prioritize
what are known as corals of opportunity
so living pieces of coral that maybe
have broken off because of a storm once
we collect the corals we bring them back
to the farm and put them in our tanks so
we use two main processes to grow the
corals micro fragmenting and assisted
evolution both pioneered by our original
advisors dr david vaughn and dr ruth
gates the process of microfragmenting
you take one piece of coral and if you
cut up the coral into these tiny little
microfragments and you place them near
each other it triggers a natural healing
process these corals will actually fuse
back into themselves almost like scar
tissue so that we can grow some of these
important slower growing species in
months or years instead of decades and
centuries at the same time the
land-based system gives us advantages
such as being able to control the
conditions in our tanks basically we can
give corals the spa treatment or we can
take them to the gym we can make the
conditions just the way they like it for
health or for growth or we can say raise
the temperatures bring them back down
stress harden the corals mimic
projections for future ocean conditions
so that the corals growing in our tanks
can better survive oceans of the future
and this is an element of this field
known as assisted evolution once we've
grown the corals in the tanks we then go
out to pre-selected and surveyed reef
sites and plant those corals into them
and the corals then attach to the reef
and will grow over sometimes overnight
you can see changes so with these
efforts we look to help preserve reefs
for the future as we then hopefully see
our leaders step up to stop killing them
and protect them to begin with one of
the innovations we brought to the table
through coral vita is this
mission-driven commercial model so
rather than simply relying on grants and
donations we're actually looking at the
incredible benefits that reefs provide
as a driving force to get stakeholders
to pay to restore and protect them so we
have a few core pillars to our business
model selling restoration as a service
eco-tourism conservation finance and
adopt-a-coral there's a number of
interesting mechanisms that are coming
online to fund projects like ours there
are reef insurance policies being
developed because they protect
coastlines from storms blue bonds and
foreign debt being forgiven in exchange
for the money being spent on
conservation a lot of people know about
carbon credits buyer diversity credits
are becoming a thing so all of these
offer opportunities to help fund
restoration work but our ultimate vision
is that there are large-scale land-based
coral farms in every nation with reefs
around the world
[Music]
in 2021 we were honored to be awarded
the inaugural revive r oceans earthshot
prize this is a prize created to help
fund and inspire solutions for the
threats that we all face winning the
prize came with a million pounds which
is quite remarkable and it's going to
help us scale and innovate even more
effectively but really i think what's
most important about it is there's an
inspiration factor that we all as we
learn can create solutions to solve
these challenges that we shouldn't just
give in to doom and gloom i often
describe myself as an optimistic realist
there are things each one of us can do
to take care of coral reefs and take
care of the planet that in turn takes
care of us vote with your wallet and
voted the ballot blocks for leaders that
are actually stepping up and doing their
job and solving for the climate crisis
and habitat destruction we also can eat
more responsibly advocate for marine
protected areas adopt corals or come
visit these places and put your money
into the communities that really rely on
healthy ecosystems and often are at the
front line of the climate crisis but
ultimately i think it's important for us
to realize that while we do have the
power and should take the responsibility
to make changes ourselves the onus
really is upon a select handful of
governments and industries and financial
players who have the power and are not
stepping up to solve for these problems
we should not feel that it's simply
individual choices that are responsible
for the crisis we're in because they're
frankly not that being said we hope that
folks will have the opportunity to
advocate on behalf of coral reefs and
even come down and plant corals with us
one day soon and together we can
collectively take care of these
ecosystems
[Music]
you